for all the people out there shouting
that Edward Snowden should have gone
through the the proper channels Tom
Drake and Bill Binney Kirk Wiebe and Ed
Loomis did go through the proper
channels and all of them fell under
criminal investigation for having done
so I am Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
and today we're talking with jesselyn
Radack she's a lawyer who is represented
many whistleblowers such as John
Kiriakou Thomas Drake and Edward Snowden
she's a whistleblower herself as well
and she's now the national security and
Human Rights director had exposed facts
jessalyn thanks for talking to us thank
you for having me let's work through
some of your kind of greatest hits and
then we'll talk about larger issues
related to surveillance and the security
state you used to work at the Department
of Justice during and during the
prosecution of John Walker Lindh the
American Taliban from what a dozen years
ago almost now what happened in that
case and how did that change your entire
framework of thinking about government
accountability I was in the ethics
attorney for the Justice Department you
know despite giving advice not to
interrogate the so-called American
Taliban without his lawyer and also not
to torture him it was clear the US was
doing both and then I advised not to use
that information in a criminal
prosecution I was informed unambiguously
that he had counsel and because of that
like with any American I would say if he
has counsel you need to allow him his
attorney for any kind of custodial
interrogation that was on a Friday and
the Justice Department office said I was
dealing with called back on Monday and
said well the FBI interrogated him
anyway what do we do now I said well you
can use that information for national
security and intelligence gathering but
not for criminal prosecution because it
was an improper interrogation without
kids and when the criminal prosecution
came up all of your emails on this went
missing from the official record that's
correct
there was a department-wide discovery
you order for all Justice Department
correspondent stealing with John Walker
Lindh interrogation the prosecutor had
two of mine but I had written more than
a dozen that were reflected pretty badly
on the FBI and I went to check the file
back then we kept hard copies of things
and they were not in the file I
resurrected them from my computer
archives and wrote a memo to my boss and
attached them and resigned as I'm not
going to be a part of whatever is going
on what had brought you to the
Department of Justice that was my career
ambition was to be a lifelong public
servant but then when it got completely
politicized in my case after 9/11 to the
point that we were looking the other way
when there are pictures trophy photos
going around the world of an American
being tortured by our people it really
caused a crisis of conscience for me
let's talk about torture for a second
because one of the people you did
represent was John Kiriakou who brought
torture to the forefront what did he do
and what happened to him John Kiriakou
was the first CIA agent who actually
publicly confirmed that torture was an
official United States program that we
were waterboarding people and said
unequivocally torture is wrong and we
shouldn't be in the business of doing it
during the subsequent years after that
interviewed the CIA filed six crimes a
report spawned carry a coup trying to
get the Justice Department to prosecute
him and it wasn't until the Obama
administration's opened war on
whistleblowers using the Espionage Act
that he wasn't that prosecuted on a
couple of counts of espionage and to
violating the intelligence identity
protection act like a number of
Espionage Act defendants he didn't
actually plead guilty to committing
espionage what did he end up
sentence John ended up getting 30 months
in jail and served two and a half years
in jail and part of that under house
arrest and now he's on probation but
really this is one of the smartest
people I've ever met
speaks multiple languages including ones
we need right now for people in
government service like Arabic and he
will never work in the government again
though he remains staunchly patriotic I
mean most of the people that I represent
have spent their entire adult lives
serving in the military or working for
the government they are true believers
and I think they still do believe that
this can be fixed or they wouldn't have
blown the whistle and they wouldn't
continue to speak out they feel like we
had we're not at the point of no return
that there still can be some sort of
pull back on this well that describes in
many ways Thomas Drake one of your
clients who along with people like
William Binney and Kirk Wiebe went
through the official chat where they
went through what channels seemed to be
official at the time Drake was an NSA
whistleblower who talked about wire
warrantless wiretapping what happened to
him Thomas Drake went through every
conceivable internal channel about a
number of surveillance programs he was
talking mostly it one called trailblazer
but he went to his boss he went to the
NSA general counsel he went to the House
and Senate intelligence committees and
testified in to 911 inquiries and not
only did they fail to redress his
concern they turned around and
prosecuted him and prosecuted him for
espionage so for all the people out
there shouting that Edward Snowden
should have gone through the proper
channels first of all they're not that
many channels for national security and
intelligence whistleblowers they are
excluded from most avenues available to
other was
but second of all Tom Drake and Bill
Binney Kirk Wiebe and Ed Loomis did go
through the proper channels and all of
them fell under criminal investigation
for having done so let's talk about
Snowden your most famous client who
recently joined Twitter and immediat
almost immediately got over a million
followers what is different about
Snowden the appeal that he seems to have
to a wide range of people who otherwise
look askance at whistleblowers I think
with Snowden there a number of
differences first of all he has publicly
said that he studied the cases of Tom
Drake and Bill Binney and how they had
gone through proper channels and how
they got completely lambasted and
skewered for doing that
and made his decision differently to go
directly to reporters give the
information to reporters and let them
use their editorial judgment about what
was in the public interest to know he
also had what a lot of whistleblowers
don't have which is documentary evidence
that's very hard to obtain or actually
remove from an agency he's young he
appeals to many different communities he
appeals to a very youthful activist
community he appeals to civil
libertarians he appeals to progressive
Democrats he has broad cross-section
appeal he's incredibly articulate and he
doesn't want to be the center of
attention now that's a problem for every
was the blower they want to shoot the
messenger rather than listen to the
message what is the likely disposition
of his case over the coming 10 years or
so will he ever be able to come back to
the United States in anything other than
chains I think he will eventually be
able to come back to the United States I
don't think it will be within the next
ten years necessarily though since 2013
we have seen a big shift in US support
of him
40% of people you know 60% thought it
was terrible 40% thought he was had done
a good thing and now those numbers are
reversed a lot he has a lot more public
support but like the public support he
enjoys and countries around the world
the political leadership is still not
going to treat him well and in fact he
just said and the BBC interview he did
that the Department of Justice has not
offered him any kind of plea deal even
though he has expressed a willingness to
go to jail talk about the scrambled
politics of this because I think going
into it and you know certainly in the
early 2000s you know when you see
somebody like John Ashcroft as Attorney
General who was telling people don't you
know raise the Phantom of lost liberties
to you know ever say anything bad about
the government a lot of people were
willing to say ok this is you know
right-wing conservatives versus
left-wing peacenik Democrats but that is
not at all how it's played out no I mean
so many left-wing people when Obama was
elected suddenly became very centrist on
a lot of the more controversial programs
that were occurring under Bush and
people are like well if a Republican did
that they would have been skewered which
is true I mean Obama came in on day one
it was like we're ending torture were
closing Guantanamo were going to be the
most open and transparent administration
and has done the complete opposite on on
all three of those but you again okay
well you got rid of torture but you
instituted a drone program that I think
is even more frightening because at
least if you're tortured you you can
live right to tell the story right it's
out to tell the story we're talk a
little bit about yeah and it's a
horrible situation where we're saying
you know torture is preferable to drone
strikes right as a policy we talk about
exposed facts and what you're hoping to
accomplish there
where is the best place for people to
find out more information about sure
expose facts is a nonprofit organization
that was created to encourage whistle
blowing and adversarial journalism I am
starting a new program there called the
whistleblower and source protection
program because for me I've always said
that the war on whistleblowers is really
a backdoor war on journalists and just
as often whistleblowers usually are the
source journalists are appear throughout
every single whistleblower indictment
and I think there is a war on
journalists and a broader war on
information going on in our country or
who's gonna win that were you hopeful
that kind of new media and new
technologies which on the one hand gives
the government more ways to surveil you
but on the other way also gives these
outlets for expression that you know
wouldn't have happened even ten years
ago I like to be optimistic and agreeing
with my client Edward Snowden that if
Congress doesn't take care of this that
tech will and you can see that I mean
Tech has gone ahead and created amazing
encryption devices and you could see the
government's frustration with that
because now in the UK and the US and
Australia they are trying to outlaw
encryption so you know I
and again the judicial branch I feel
like is finally turning on these issues
and ruling that secret surveillance is
unconstitutional and probably illegal so
I do see change going on in that branch
of government I'm hoping that ultimately
technology and Internet freedom will
prevail in this struggle well we'll
leave it there I hope you're right we've
been talking about jesselyn Radack she
is that exposed facts and she's a lawyer
to many whistleblowers and hopefully
more to come
jessalyn thanks for talking to us thank
you for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie